all right Alex hello well welcome back
to simulation uh-huh the fourth time
were sitting down together I'll show ya
and let's hear the update so how have
you been
how's Cambridge been how's the Bay Area
been this yeah I've haven't been in the
Bay Area since like left last September
so it's like it's like a refreshing of
say hmm so I see here you know so it's
like a refresh of like all the places
that I missed out on so that last time
that I can get I can get today special
since a large ins of update since then I
have a better
I love stuff will change so quickly over
time yeah I originally came back to stay
here because I was I was basically dawn
by leered by a certain update by an aunt
I ate and ate and marinate association
18 associations invite Jin Yong
jun-hyung basically hosted an event and
they get something in effect so awesome
with a yeah so I ended up going there I
ended everything Cosmo melky to come
there too and yeah it was like it was
like a gathering of like all the top of
the top in morning you can be spirits
from the US which is important
especially because I know with this it's
not just about aging is that once you're
interested in it you cannot be
uninterested in it because it affects
everything like it affects the rest of
your entire life for most of most people
stay most of their life in an aged state
rather than in the most optimal useful
state than they exist but anyway is back
to the point me and some of my friends
we got updates on say where do the hot
air to new people are looking into alpha
chromosome dynamics and even though like
I generally I don't know
prefer online informants of interaction
the fact as a matter that matter is that
the log of a lot of people still do real
life with an interaction where you where
your fastest learning rates are just
local artists local and also you see
which were like like that's too
enthusiastic and getting to know you
with repeated exposure to some people
over time you just know which people
give you more over what more will you
give you information and Zach you can
learn faster than reading a dead dead
paper paper book so yeah so yeah some
stuff at also I was it was amazing to be
a being a reunion of like buck Institute
and Kate brilliant lab people and if
those people who are appreciate you
doing the most especially because I've
had interaction with you Mike a
Brazilian slab for quite some time and
also I've interacted with buckets do
people true yeah you reminding me how
it's similar for when I go to Cambridge
it's like me also visiting the powerful
clusters of people decided that I'm
getting either an update yeah you're
kind of doing that for the Bay Area one
yeah yeah also I finally met this one
friend Brady McLean who came it came
from
he works for Cruz now he's like an
integrator of a lot of influence I've
been exposed like he lives its Masonic
house it's a teal fellow caesareans
remember group a spec house and he also
was involved it was a rationality /ei
community so who knows he was there he
and because he works on the machine
learning algorithms based and he also
knows Jeremy Nixon and that style spade
crew so he said he's the ones who
basically like knows information flows
that he's exposed to a set of integrated
information flows in most Co from the
North North Bay or South Bay aren't
exactly exposed to like who's what in
the early less strong career it's most
people mostly who work in AAA problems
they they're not that interested in most
say big picture
AIE self-improvement stuff the rationals
are into and people oftentimes hates
rationals for it but I still sink
threatens have a lot of merde like even
chairman Nixon he saves and will we
invade they both say I don't Catholic
appeal so many people hate the rationals
group but you we could faith they say
they still have a lot going on even
though they they also have like
a lot of floss that prevents them from
basically being the best being the
perfect people who can't save the work
who will have the most power to save the
world even though they used to think
that that the you see the you see would
dream about a game in the world um so
yeah so Bray McLean he's also like kind
of knows how he he was also one of the
early founders from the event horizon
the house which with like a legend their
house with with a little olive herb Rica
and basically oh and early see if I
retreat shoot people choose so it's like
so many important communities and and
this music that's like so open about
themselves and they have so many
constraints awful people that you just
have to get you know know what they are
for those that don't yet know Alex which
communities would you say you are most
involved with it is there the air
quality sensor yeah that thing is so
important for health and longevity I
agree with you totally
so which ones which ones would you say
you say aging is one of your hot ones
would you say now effective altruism is
another big one I am just I'm just there
I'm not really something else I'm like
I'm like I guess somehow was somehow
naturally integrated to the information
flows of the infinity super wild since
I've been there for a while i I just I'm
just like a source and think of
information that that's not very many
other people have are and it even though
like I I want to grant I want to be in
other community suggests yeah you just
learned so much about human nature and
timid psychology by being interview
begins they're very thrilled you talk
about anything and everything they have
like a shared collective history that
you and the group groups to as group
story a group theology that starts from
days and yeah just one of the best
captured the social group said that the
best have a sense of sense of self a
sense of how it was how it evolved like
with respect with call it with college
say college culture a lot of times seen
through cycle after four years and
people tend to be ignorant of what the
past
why even though like I know some people
from Catholic who seem to have kept plot
of their schools to social drama over
spirits Oh up here it's that might have
lasted like more than eight years but
not what why isn't that and for those
that weren't at June's event and also
the aging conference that you were at in
San Jose
what is happening at the cutting edge of
aging right now a lot of scenes and I I
would not necessarily say that the
material desire is at the cutting edge
it's very it's presented the way it has
to be understandable to most of the
Asian community so so I did get you see
like so basically like mainstream aging
research when it's still like [ __ ] more
focus on characteristic and play
troublesome I dynamics let's come at
summer dynamics part also like
opportunity and genetic measure it the
part remarking Lavina biometric
epigenetic genetic aging just new
measures up met new measures that
basically measuring how an organism age
that's like that's like recent series
art but it's also not like not exactly
george church cutting-edge level of
research as in the top of the synthetic
biology stuff that changes everything
it's not exactly that that attorney says
doctor he couldn't for me to like follow
and not get lost like if you show most
synthetic biology or gene editing
research which is that's the gene
editing that's with cutting-edge but
they don't really know aging that
they're the mode
Mooresville yeah but yeah and is it that
the unraveling of telomeres is the most
important part of chromosomal dynamics
no that's that's just the easiest most
you understand you internalized there
are so many others like for example the
how lamin a it's a it's important for us
a criminal for for making sure that pro
the chromosomes are translated properly
or like or for provision of the
chromosomes in which part which parts
are like tethered to the their wave of
tethering the chromosomes that don't
become too loose and oftentimes
of aging is one where we're say the
chromosomes are loosened up and in and
and you lose information about the the
the precise dirty Amish stoichiometry
trait which parents should be translated
in which time also when big issue of
aging is that oftentimes there is
something known as ER stress and Golgi
stress or also just a lot of time a lot
of times when you have proteins protein
unfolding stress in which case like you
did you just have proteins fat to get
translated as inappropriate time so we
don't get the localization signal
factored in anyways the point is when
proteins are traveling the south
acceptance sentence when sense stress
when curtains aren't translate
translated in at the same proportions
which then like it gives the ER stress
response but yeah
anyway some other points were people
went deeper down and choose they stand
with have metabolic pathways like a
tryptophan degradation or flavin flavin
1888 flat rather than flavin and I
didn't see model nucleases and how
changing expression of these affects
longevity also more ways of measuring
there's there say another one was a
message development person who basically
did did use the age of like trying to
pretension that pretty not yeast and
yeast microfluidic the fluid it's like a
new micro flows it was divisive to to
basically capture automatically captured
capture a cell separate out cells based
on properties like I know in the
Cambrian lab there you have a lot of
people who just hit who did a lot of out
of made the yeast they it wouldn't add
me just count talking about so did he
send a lot of undergrads who do and
wasn't exactly the best season labor but
now that now that there's being more
automated it's like alibi elements the
elegans analysis the way there's other
people in
it's like the launch of research
institutes which they're constantly
starting which which is spatially
transmitted to ways of automating
testing of all these new drugs and
metabolites on c.elegans or fast also
people are trying to find a fine new
model organisms which hopefully get and
basically like it's only mechanistic
understanding of this there's still not
modification modification like enhanced
messes of delivery delivery in situ new
cells is as more since either biology or
George her stuff razzing traditional
Asian research that wasn't really
covered it and and as much death it's
obvious that you're so deep in in the
field would you would you say that one
of the easiest ways to explain what is
aiming to be done is to retain the
youthful homeostatic capacity for our
rest of our lives
yeah homeostasis operating without the
ability of a cell to respond to
stressors this is one of the scenes that
goes goes most are with age like for
example kudasai I mean it's depleted so
quickly with age it's all due to please
so quickly it was exposure to say chew
cigarette smoke or even e-cigarettes and
there's like one of the reasons why
people get behind alcohol hangover so
quickly even after the twenty is that's
when a lot of scenes decline but we can
recover ability to recover from
all-nighters or stress like this
basically this is it this is often
template declines first yeah yeah okay
and then I want to also help people get
on a on a super connector level so
that's some Aging's yeah let's talk on a
super connector level now so I'm curious
whenever I come to you know when it last
time I came to Cambridge in May it was
very evident that you were going through
and making tons and tons of connections
to people that that we should interview
and and it also hit me that Cambridge is
another really dense cluster of people
that are building the future and in many
ways it's science driven rather than in
this in Silicon Valley in many ways
entrepreneurship driven so it's kind of
some differences there everything as a
start-up versus there's more science
research so it sparked in me the desire
to want to make a second recording
studio in Cambridge as soon as possible
hopefully in 2020 and just be able to
sit down with more and more people out
there more frequently and I'm curious
how does how does one end up figuring
out this balance it seems as though you
are really heavy on this edge tennis
information patch jumping so you spend
most of your time talking to other
people about the edge of the field that
they're researching and you jump from
conversation to conversation and from
edge of field to edge a field whereas
for example like with me I have to spend
a pretty decent amount of my time on not
talking to people I have to like
actually get into focus mode and so do
you find yourself getting into focus
mode as well as the edge tennis that
you're playing not yet at the moment
though I go to focus moment at any time
obviously I could like be reading about
comes to papers all the [ __ ] time
what's that all certified agent org is
or like been thest or like some of those
other people who are like real into
aging yeah I just find that some of them
reading I maximize amount of information
I learned for soon a second if I don't
focus and somehow the fact is that if
you be doing that this is no one else is
doing which produces that on yourself so
this is so this is as though the amount
of cutting-edge knowledge per second
that you can achieve is greatest when
you talk to other people at the edge of
their fields about their research yeah
yeah rather than reading biochemistry
books or papers or watching videos that
type of yeah that's one way of doing it
I used I started off publishing papers
which I still think is a fast way
assuming that knows it's a fact the
fastest way to look you lead your fields
if you learn textbooks so really it's
like reading textbooks while in the
center
of where of where all activities
happening so long for you have perfect
intentional control which note which
very people people have in fact earlier
today during that event people were
vassar Jeremy and I were talking about
basically like which people seem to be
completely in control of themselves and
hidden same very many people say Jeff
Bezos or Dennis Hasset I see they were
also asking which people seem to be the
smart as Martin would people they know
and who were in completely in control of
of what and taken out to take and look
and like not bound to weird weird rules
and then their own people they could
name people like Jeff Bezos or Dennis
Hasset Asst basically completely free
and whereas other times like even if
you're a CEO you're still held back by
other people and what they expect of you
and in all those meetings which
apparently is what happens to a lot of
fortune 500 companies and people just
don't have the same agency they used to
even though it appears they're super
high status he they're the leader of the
company but they still don't exactly
have a type of control Jeff Bezos has so
as though that having complete
governance over one's own input stream
is yeah priority yeah I even ask every
dollar was one of them and they said
wait Alan doesn't exactly have Optima
because I could have function even
though he out for out there's a lot of
stuff away in in an amazing way he might
do it in which you compensate for let's
say not being not being in full control
of and so they were even mentioning
stuff about Peter Thiel versus whether
about Peter Thiel and vets garry
kasparov and like if pierre teal really
in as much control over over scenes as
we like if he is because he has entire
networks it forms around him but it's
still like even if you're like a venture
capital venture capitalist and ceremony
at people it's still like you don't have
complete ability to chew can chew
control command people they if you could
trust him on words and especially when
they don't have them tired all the time
in the world you do due diligence and so
I think a would that I think due
diligence would
I think there might be a b a b c who
does a perfect way of doing to diligence
where they do due diligence on the hyper
open people and hyper open people who
people willing to be hyper open who
might not get other opportunities might
sometime in the future get get sided by
say a due diligence Vichy and get
invention based on that simple because
they will they would have to allow
themselves a possibility of say oh of
say because it's their form of trust
that that happens when your lawyer since
we would say more at you be to be
tracked a little bit more than other
people are willing to be tracked okay so
it seems as though there's different
colors on the color wheel of people's
behavior patterns in our world so some
people are just on the playground
playground just playing other people are
on the playground but they want to solve
problems and make the the civilization
prosper over time more effect yeah yeah
and then there's also people that within
that subgroup of wanting to make the
world better spend me spend most of
their time on what you do versus what
let's say someone else does which is you
can you can bounce from conversation a
conversation and help push conversations
out at the edge of of knowledge while
other people are maybe doing things like
some of the people that work at startups
or companies that are actually kind of
building things in the in that are
building physical things in the 3d world
that then yeah yeah they can't search
for each other very well
right now as as most that's like the
Internet there's a certain there was a
certain group of people who are on the
edge of that group of like Devon's you
girl or Patrick Collison or Tyler Cowen
or tollbooths house people where they're
like two or axiom Outman where they're
like generating into a tweet stream of
the of the edge
and it's sadly does not continue very
many people from chora which is like a
huge we're the cute another because you
expected that they get algae cords that
almost none of them none of the people
other could edge of the Twittersphere
are like people who used to be big in
Korra but anyways the point is yeah it's
like you need to figure out how do you
make it easy like really figure out how
to make the basically make one ism
explain the value of the other person
more more more to others it's like even
even if I drew thousands say more
crowdfunding or more of wage you like
that so he knows that this edge is
talking about patientís systems like
Alexi Gusev and and and Patrick Collison
and that could be what they're all
talking about basically trying to build
better patronage decisions especially
because nowadays there's more money
available than ever in a sense and most
cheap most most non-greek rent-seeking
occupation products are much cheaper
than they used to be even even if the
even if say the occupation of the
licensing / rent seeking seeking scenes
are driving prices up those thing is
like it's so much it's so easy to get
new computers are sort of hard drives
and ever before or like start creating
scenes because like the stuff and also
programming it's also just easier to
program than ever it was before and
let's hit a couple let's hit a couple
things here one of the things is that to
be in full control of one's own input
stream yeah so this is a and also being
able to decide if you want to build in
the 3d world if you want to just play oh
yeah different people at the edge of
their fields so to be in full control of
that to know how to designate
parts of what you have to do to other
people in order for your time to free up
and also to the whole embedded growth
obligation that these organizations have
yeah that we have to figure out because
it seems as though at times the
corporation may not we may not want that
corporation to continue
they're embedded growth trajectory and
that it may actually just be better for
that company to to take a to take a
hiatus potentially or even to just break
off into separate sub sub sections of an
organization or to just stop
functionality completely but the whole
that that the shareholders have to
continue earning dividends over time the
company has to stay even though it may
actually be harming the social fabric
rather than benefiting it okay so that's
a bit on the on the nodes and and edge
tennis and input streams and to be in
full control of one's input stream so
critical I really enjoyed that point now
and not falling for opportunity obesity
either we're so overly saturated with
opportunities that we take them without
realizing that we can potentially have
greater control over hanging out with
certain people or reading certain things
well things are so rocket are ourselves
sometimes knowing cutting people off
it's like something that many of the
most effective before node you doing but
could but also cutting people often wait
that didn't seem rude or how can I do
that example think about that metastases
yes he cut a lot dwarf because whenever
he goes people people surround him Peter
teal he obviously came so fast why I've
seen some Peter Thiel talks where at the
end of the session everyone [ __ ]
crowds around him just think anyone even
the Dalai Lama or like or that famous
kind people once you reach a certain
level of fame you just have to cut
people off forget that one surrounds it
surrounds you so then you just have to
develop an intrepid stream where say you
give people second chances
because I think the mark of kindness is
literally giving people second chances
sometimes often at first the first
question someone tried to approach her
chew with it's not exactly the most well
form question it made also all the times
it may not be the moat the questions
that people who are truth seeking well
if they will go after begin because
people they just want a chance to chew
chew have bragging rights you're talking
or remembered by the person even though
oftentimes what people would literally
go up to famous people are you trying to
be remember
memorize them or just you have assurance
that their even that even that someone
else is not like can you say something
profound enough in the five-second
window you have with the high power yes
yeah that they want to pass more time
with you and that's a very tough thing
yeah yes Eve but it's important to take
your time on formulating exactly
compressing of really powerful couple
sentences into what someone would think
is worthwhile for you to hang out with
yeah
they don't remember their presence their
answer it's like people asking people
ask that someone else would do anything
of this sort thing about in real life
and neither psyche it remembers in the
long run that's why that's why I'm
generally it I don't have a very high
preference and shifting most
communication online where it who
actually will remember teens and then
what do you think about the movement
which it seems as though it's happening
where people are tapping into the social
fabric finding their other key let's say
tennis player slash executors that they
want to collaborate with and then they
kind of unplug from the social fabric so
that they don't have to get Bing Bing
Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing that they they
can then focus like Yuri Herrera do I
know other people who they they have to
like Alf attempts have to announce it
publicly in a way so she's domain
enforcement also to make sure that
people don't get mad at them in case he
do fall off for periods of time it's
like but you have to maintain the
discipline in order to do it and it
often times people who have a privilege
should do so people also have a
privilege to do that when they are
sufficiently socially or financially
secure that they don't need to keep in
reporting to someone else or their
audience like think they have the
confidence that they won't be forgotten
or that their friends will actually come
back to them or want to come back to
them after taking these like say six
months breaks or high a disease in
sometimes that even conflicts with
people's traditional nodes of
friendships which sway like some friends
of friends fall apart because there's
there's a symmetry between how much each
want to talk to each other and sometimes
people have to cut off odd friends
because of this yeah the asymmetry with
how often people want to talk and also
it's as though when your mind gets
expanded to new ways of thinking it's
really hard to go back to having
conversations that are of old ways of
thinking so that's another one of the
things is that we don't I find I'm
finding myself more and more asking
people what do you do when you have to
cut off Alex because because it I have
to focus more and more of my time alone
and not replying to people and so what
do you how do you could disconnect from
people Alex with politely
I don't disconnect people right now I
think the standard way to 215 it's
announcement announcement that you're
planning to do it on on your blog or
social media it's probably best doing on
their blog or some sites where people
just google your name easily and just
see that you're disconnecting though
there's also challenge in that if you
are disconnecting people may not you may
lose access to the information that
might change your life so then there's a
more optimal way there's a more optimal
way to do it potentially which is that
you say that announced on your socials
and blogs that you are that you're very
very selectively staying in touch with
certain people right now as you are a
build focused on in build mode that way
people can still reach out and you don't
lose on those opportunities but then you
can select to reply or not to those
people yeah okay that that that process
seems to be more and more important to
figure out how to do Alex let's let's um
let's end the conversation on this point
which is you initially came up to me at
EA GX in Boston and told me that certain
people and this is this is actually
really good feedback you told me that
certain people won't take interviews
with me because I'm not smart enough and
I was like this is great because I need
to hear feedback like this it's it's
very
it's very rare that people are as
eccentric as you that they're able to
just be like hey Alan did you know that
some people won't take interviews with
you because you're not smart enough and
I found that to be excellent because
this is important feedback and so if we
can have more people that behave in this
like super transparent honest and way
that I think it'll help people grow so
will you deliver the feedback from that
you gave me then and also that you're
giving that you gave me even before we
started streaming here where you were
telling me that that sometimes the
things that that I say can sound a
little bit like jargony and that how I
can help
buzz wordy how can I be a better
interviewer in general please okay so
let's see here one scene is um I think
first of all I haven't watched many of
the interviews because I'm like I prefer
text whenever possible and that's
something that's coming guys it's coming
soon that we're gonna have
transcriptions for every single episode
and knowledge graphs for every episode
yes we're gonna work on that it's gonna
come yet like with Peter until it's very
yeah yeah this is very good and we know
that those are really key points on our
upcoming agenda it's and as you all know
that if we can get your help through
patreon PayPal cryptocurrency donations
we can more easily get to that point
together so please do support us all the
links are in the bio in order to to make
that happen and so that's totally on our
agenda those things and I'm glad that
you mentioned because it's a frequent
thing that we're starting to hear now
from people is that I prefer
transcriptions I just want to parse find
the key points myself or also knowledge
graphs will show you the key points
highlight reels 5-minute highlight reel
of a one-hour episode are also things
that we're working on yeah yeah okay so
yeah continue please on the feedback
yeah so they say that they they say you
were a bit but whirring noise they say
like some people who I've talked to who
who like some some some people were like
very clear sinkers like another scene of
that maybe maybe the space of things you
say it's a little bit constraint and not
the most creative perhaps which means
that maybe you're not you're not the
most sophisticated or critical thinker
or you can you can't imagine every
single you can't infinitely your brain
can't infinitely adapt you imagining
everything of every single way every
single basically like every possible way
of expressing certain feeling their
sentiments some people are just more
verbal expression than others and they
and they will identify no awake we do
create creative experience okay let me
let me take a couple things here one of
the things is that verbal agility
abstract thinking let's let's take a
couple let's take a couple things here
one of the things is that the the the
thought of of being a generalist which
we talked about a little bit as well as
that it becomes when you when we were
generalist it becomes harder to
potentially play tennis across all of
the different depths of the fields but
we can maybe help make good transfer
connections of ideas transfer learning
connections across fields which helps a
lot people but the Machine like I said
it's it's it's it's so difficult to
actually be able to you're right that
the the Creed the amount of creative
permutations that oh that one could run
on how certain fields could relate to
other years and and have having me hit
back a thought that's really profound a
novel for the other person I'm not a
machine that can do that quite yet in
the in the greatest caliber maybe what
I'm mented further that I can do fine
grading also people when people use the
word transfer you learn it's also a uses
buzzword interdisciplinary and also
another buzzword
why are those like buzz words rather
than just words they're so frequently
you they're so frequently used because
they were their way of saying making
people seem sophisticated or making seem
be able seem like there's a puts
inclusive appear open-minded and there's
definitely a social tendency which a
virtuous take the open-mindedness
because
open-minded Essene that's like a huge
virtue in this in an innovation driven a
and um whenever it's seen as a virtue
people are inclined to signal that they
have more of it than they actually do
even just for social acceptance to be
taken seriously or the fact that being
open-minded is necessary but not
sufficient in order to do it in fact I
think some virtual signaling happens
around necessary but not sufficient
scenes people have to do in order to
actually be serious about something okay
and then let's say that where where are
the ways that an interviewer can stay
open-minded what are those key practices
that they can do to stay open-minded but
then also not not come off buzz wordy
like you should I give the question
immediately after they finish or should
I save a sentence or two and then ask
the question so one thing this sometimes
sometimes you get good people a list of
questions they most want asked or
answered sometimes and that's usually
what we do before the show we sit down
as we co-create the outline yeah once
what's the one reason why I didn't have
a strong preference for online format
since all the forms are asynchronous and
you can and like there's no time
pressure so sometimes like almost
realize and like harissa that what was
the a suppressing seems that they're
under pressure to confront and every
response even if it's not a great
response or even if it even if it's not
possible this one but anyway the point
is a lot of a lot of responses they need
more time to sink out before they
actually responds and video editing and
certainty of to make it easier than all
the manual labor involved video editing
which is why we do the live stream yeah
helps so much with ya component and then
okay and then how about on what would
you what would be your ideal interview
process like for you and other people at
the edge of the fields like these people
that say that Alan's not smart enough to
interview me yet right that type of a
person
what would Alan need to do in order what
would the skill of B's that I need to
learn in order to be
interview smarter okay I think it would
be good you have someone comment on
someone who's like who watches all the
electrics just comment on your
performance over time like exposure okay
you guys heard that give more comments
about about the perform my performance
over time as an interviewer and at while
you're at it if you're doing that to
also comment about Ron's performance as
well doing the technical production and
directing because he's also starting to
you know really do well with the
competition's embedding assets in that
time also make pre predictions behind
you and Rupa what you were really
thinking about what what stress
throughout the most what's were the most
difficult incidents you have to make and
what you were struggling restraint you
think about but didn't before the one
reasonable video interviews of that they
captured the moment just in time and
take have in a way that makes it easy to
access memory such came just before and
afters an interview yeah it's like it's
like one one of the best ways you do
mind uploading is basically to just
capture all the video of life logging in
to capture video features as possible
because some more if you need to capture
them all either is in the brain to
figure out which figure out exactly
which which precepts are needed to
access what you were actually seeing it
at the point of time so you can't go
back as an improving it like I don't
know who to a video game players of
course players who were meals to watch
over them and as long as you get the
right feedback or you you are not
distracted by haters Commons or non
truth seeking comments or an unhelpful
comments then then you will basically
get like the best feedback ever although
some of the people can seem like people
who are a bias it seems in some ways
people who like the most creative people
don't don't heavily rely on other people
in order to do it too most most of the
most creative people do it seems alone
though I see what I'm saying yeah yeah
why I got to spend a lot more time alone
I'm starting to realize that yeah it
helps a lot
i I feel like what you're what you're
saying about having someone that can
maybe be a little bit more down the line
also with some additional potentially
funding is there could be somebody that
specifically focuses on just
the development I'm frequently
reflecting on myself but I think that if
someone I think even Jeremy went ahead
and even hired someone to just
personally yeah like amplify his
productivity by like following him
around and saying like hey you said that
you were gonna do this thing you're not
doing this thing yeah so that type of
stuffs also quite interesting how about
on an on an on an open-mindedness Alex
it seems as though that the the most the
most generalists find themselves to be
as open minded as possible to be able to
take in this mosaic of world views that
ends up actually developing out into
what I would say is the most truth is
when you can simultaneously abstractly
reason 8 billion people's perspectives
you have the most true world view and
it's really difficult for a human brain
to be able to do that but can you
literally see how someone from China
sees a certain issue how someone from
the US or someone from the Middle East
yeah I think people need to be capturing
more of their input history and what
infinity 11 through recent conclusions
that they read in each one I think
people are secretive about this because
they're insecure about being falsified
or they're just insecure about it for a
variety of reasons it's just not what
some humans originally do and make
people creeped out we're just gonna side
because it's also inhibits us from
reaching and say sounder epistemic
States and then people also don't don't
know what even led you to think this way
yeah yeah and then it's like privileged
information when somebody behind NDA's
yeah yeah so logging one's own input
stream more effectively I mean are like
my input stream specifically is very
evident with literally the people we
feature on the show there's these type
of it's still not enough totally yeah
even the amount of yeah other content
that I that I that I consumed correct
books I read videos i watch all that
type of stuff but then the output
streams also quite evident in terms of
the things that I'm like the worried the
ways that the world view is being
augmented over time yeah evident that is
with the the ways that I'm speaking
about it
okay and then maybe any last sort of
bits of advice as an interviewer that I
could embody um probably ask for
feedback from the other person's about
what's they were expecting what they
were maybe not were me before and after
both before and after prefer it but not
in a way that would exhaust them or
cause them to behave like adversity this
is the thing is that when people come in
at first it's all about making them feel
super comfortable that they're gonna
radiate from their heart as best as they
can they're gonna sit there they're
gonna rock it and then if I'm asking
them hey like what are your expectations
it's kind of like that can maybe hinder
some yeah I can't also I don't like
realize those classes even though
they're important it's just it's not
what my minds focus on right now let's
just do a lot of like polite advice
towards polite signaling like expect
much and yeah and usually it helps when
even when I just showed them what notes
that I've made a show and that they're
able to co-create and say that they want
this or don't want that that does stuff
yeah that helps a lot
and then yeah this is this has been good
I think we covered a decent amount of
things aging super connecting
interviewing skills yeah we talked good
amount of things any other last thoughts
and the way up yeah I think there is a
chance because many more self-aware
shows and most other shows there's a
chance which if you got the right people
which I think it's going to be important
if we ever are to create a hive mind or
like a hive mind the coordinates better
because right now there's a giant global
coordination problem and the global
giant global coordination problem is why
basically why the why [ __ ] is gonna
happen unless we solve it like whether
its climate change which is like one of
the big chlorinated problems or a
certain other chord injury problems
yeah the global giant coordination
problem is needing to be over the hive
mind Alex I think one of the ways that
we can approach this this this aware
style of show is that I've repeated this
so many times it's really driving home
into my essence this is not about Alan
this is not about Ron this is not about
simulation this is about whatever is
channeling through us that is inspiring
other people to get more involved yeah
in building the future
yeah so once you do that yeah and
probably that's important tonight and
there's something that it's a real
important eight it's awful at very very
puzzle racing build in the future it's
yeah everyone talks about about this or
this value yeah and so I think there's a
delicate balance because I do think that
one shouldn't overuse that but I also
think that there is also a benefit of
spreading that meme over and over again
because when people say why are they so
obsessed with building the future why do
they always talk about that and then all
of a sudden it becomes yeah well some
people comment in and they're like oh I
you know I've started pursuing synthetic
biology or I started to pursue neuro
tech or whatever AI that people tell us
what fields they start pursuing around
from around the world but the the
general idea that if we can repeat memes
through songs or through videos right if
we can repeat memes they can become
programmed that people start caring more
about talking to their families and
their friends their co-workers about
building the future and so there's like
a delicate balance don't like overuse
don't have it be too buzz wordy but at
the same time do push the memes that you
care about spreading into the world
effectively yeah that's it's a it's a
big balance so one of the things that I
hope we do is that over time with like
you just said that if the show continues
to develop it's in a very self-aware
style that one of the it doesn't end up
diverting it itself to something that
like an outside investor or things like
that which is again why we need help to
make sure that that doesn't happen that
that we can do things like
conversation that we're having together
can we can add like we've done before to
more people three more people we have
three four five six people sitting
around and as we develop the studio we
can really make beautiful round table
conversations happening where one person
there's so much information that's lost
in people when people do meetings in
real life it's all lost after they mean
ends and it's like and then they have a
rare that's what like every comedians
because it's just talking and not doing
but if you if you can't capture what the
meeting was like there's so this little
place it totally helped and so just
totally help make sure that people
actually are crowd accountable to what
they say which doesn't happen enough
yeah and then it also becomes like were
fusing worldviews yeah we got really
beautiful that it's you it's at that
point it would be like you would get a
message and maybe like three or four or
five of our other friends would get
messages and it would say it would it
would give people an option hey like
what do you guys think about coming in
August 10th from noon to 2:00 p.m. and
if people say yes to be able to come
into those six people we requested to be
on the program we can basically start at
noon in a roundtable live live streaming
it with the multi-camera shoes yeah and
we can do a world worldview fusion it's
like where has your worldview been
updated the last two three months since
we last talked and that's what we talk
about around the table yeah Alex one
last thing on the way I want to ask you
about the I want to ask you a question
about it and I want to see what your
answer is about it where do you get all
of your nourishment where do you breathe
air where do you eat food where do you
drink water where do you get those
things from Why ask me this where do
they come from everyone's read the same
way air although I tried to breathe like
I like those bagels they come from
nature right these things come
worth that we live on right we're all
living in the same house we're all
living on the same planet or like
remnants of what was formed 4.6 billion
years ago okay
correct so we're all we're all living
here together we all breathe breathe the
air of the planet it nourishes us the
water nourish us as the food nourish us
as well such becomes there your there's
the most buzzword Ethan you're ever
saying most unoriginal but where they
think well this well I'm having
everything that I'm said that I've been
saying in that last segment actually is
directly being communicated from
spiritual leaders around playing like
indigenous wisdom because what
indigenous leaders are saying alex is
that we are extremely disconnected from
the earth that sustains us and nourishes
yes and the interconnectedness of us
with all the other organisms and
ecosystems on the planet
does that does that resonate no I know
what you mean that's what even even ever
no Wilson like puts it in the most
scientific way possible even though he's
not super into all that other stuff that
essence of our disconnection from what
stands us as as as much as we want to
just say oh that's like buzz wordy and
stuff but as much really that is
probably the most pressing issue of our
time the global coordination problem is
a direct reflection of our inability to
understand where we all come from yeah
and what sustains us does that make
sense yeah yeah okay okay because I
that's one of the memes that I think
needs to get pushed forward in our world
to fix the global coordination problem
is when you breathe the air when you eat
the food when you drink the water when
you take the shower when you exercise
when you connect to the Sun when you do
things like that it is so much more
spiritually connecting to source to
where we all come from to our
interconnectedness then when we're just
trapped in some of the news feed
algorithms that just keep us there for
financial their own personal financial
benefits their own self dealing benefits
so okay okay yeah you seem you you seem
like you're
you're more super hyper scientifically
edge of knowledge driven and maybe less
so focused on the indigenous wisdom side
of things is that would you say that
yeah yeah I think Alex I think it would
also be helpful to to to capture a
little bit of the essence of that
indigenous wisdom as you go forth at the
at the edge I think that would help a
lot yeah that maybe some feedback from
me from me to you ah yeah at the least
yeah so yeah all right
good thank you that was fought forth
conversation with you Alex good stuff
all right thanks everyone for tuning in
we greatly appreciate you'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below on
the episode let us know what you're
thinking also talk to more people your
friends family co-workers people online
on social media about the things that we
discuss about aging super connecting
about interviewing give us your thoughts
is about me and Ron as we keep
developing out the show and hold on a
second let me just close the show in
which goes show and and also check out
the links in the bio below to support us
help us grow help us prosper help us do
the things that we talked about in this
episode like making knowledge graphs
like doing cool things like making
transcripts and highlight reels all that
cool stuff and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world thank you for tuning in and we
will see you soon peace